katarische routine ist auf das
allernotwendigste reduziert es gibt nur
eine plenarsitzung diese woche die
fraktionen tagten digital mit hilfe von
telefon und videokonferenzen im
schnelldurchgang sollen heute gewaltige
hilfsmaßnahmen beschlossen werden
allein beim nachtragshaushalt über den
heute abgestimmt wird geht es um 156
milliarden euro
im plenum werden heute nur die
fraktionsvorsitzenden sitzen die
parlamentarischen geschäftsführer und
einige mitglieder der ausschüsse die mit
corona befasst sind weit von einander
entfernt selbst die besuchertribünen
dienen heute als sitzplatz für die
abgeordneten besucher dürfen ja schon
seit mitte märz nicht mehr in den
bundestag
die übrigen abgeordneten auch das ganz
ungewöhnlich die gesund sind und nach
berlin kommen konnten verfolgen die
debatte von ihren büros aus kommen dann
zur abstimmung aber auch dafür gelten
besondere vorsichtsmaßnahmen die
wahlurnen stehen jetzt draußen auf dem
flur
es sind deutlich mehr als üblich um
große menschen volks davor zu verhindern
vorbesprechungen fand ebenfalls über
telefon und videokonferenzen statt
noch hat die generaldebatte nicht
begonnen noch wird über einige
änderungen der geschäftsordnung
diskutiert das parlament muss ja zum
beispiel beschließen dass man die
rettungspakete ohne einhaltung der sonst
üblichen fristen verabschieden darf aber
vielleicht können wir trotzdem mal
gerade einen blick werfen ins plenum
ich glaube es sind einige abgeordnete
schon da dann man sieht wie weit sie
auseinander setzen das auch auf der auf
den bänken der regierung
ja sieht man dass sie weit auseinander
setzen
es beginnt jetzt die debatte der
vizekanzler scholz die rede statt der
kanzlerin damen und herren lassen sie
mich vorweg diesem haus die herzlichen
grüße der bundeskanzlerin übermitteln
die gerne dabei gewesen wäre und heute
gesprochen hätte aber sie wissen dass
sie das heute nicht machen kann
aber ich glaube auch in ihrem namen kam
ich herzliche grüße ans home office
übermitteln
wir erleben gegenwärtig eine krise die
in der geschichte der bundesrepublik
ohne vorbild ist die krise ist groß mehr
als die krisen die wir in der letzten
zeit erlebt haben und sie ist zugleich
eine schicksalhafte herausforderung für
die ganze menschheit
es gibt ja noch keine endgültig wirksam
therapeutischen maßnahmen gegen die
krankheit und das fordert jeden
einzelnen der infiziert ist ganz
besonders heraus aber es zeigt auch wie
verletzlich wir als menschen sind und es
zeigt wir es auch dass politik modelle
falsch sind die da die diese folgen dass
jeder am besten alleine zurechtkommt das
was wir jetzt brauchen ist qualität
wir sehen auch täglich die bilder und
hören die berichte nicht nur aus asien
und amerika sondern ganz unmittelbar aus
unserer nachbarschaft aus italien
spanien frankreich österreich
es ist die gemeinsame herausforderung
der weltgemeinschaft die auswirkungen
des corona virus zu bekämpfen
und deshalb wird deutschland auch und
gerade in dieser zeit zb an der seite
seiner europäischen partner stehen dass
es keine sache für uns allein wir stehen
zusammen
und ich will ausdrücklich sagen wir
vergessen auch nicht die ärmsten länder
der welt auch sie sind in dieser
situation ganz besonders auf unsere
hilfe angewiesen
die pandemie ist aber auch eine
nationale herausforderung
wir sind aufgefordert zu zeigen dass
offene und freiheitliche gesellschaften
die innere kraft besitzen mit solchen
besonderen lagen umzugehen
ja wir schränken die bewegungsfreiheit
nein aber wir setzen dabei auf die
aufgeklärte einsicht der bürgerinnen und
bürger
ja wir verlangen allen vieles ab aber es
tun wir weil sich demokratische
regierung im bund und ländern darauf
verständigen
und es ist gut dass ins freie medien und
eine kritische öffentlichkeit dabei
begleiten das öffentliche und soziale
leben in unserem land ist eingeschränkt
damit die ausbreitung des virus
verlangsamt wird
die auswirkungen sind überall spürbar
die schulpflicht ist faktisch ausgesetzt
urlauber müssen abgesagt hochzeiten
verschoben werden und ganze
wirtschaftszweige können ihren
geschäften nicht mehr nachgehen
die allermeisten bürgerinnen und bürger
um verständnis für diese maßnahmen und
sie halten sich dann aber trotzdem vor
uns liegen harte wochen
und doch wir können sie bewältigen das
merken müssen
viele von uns improvisieren leben neue
form des arbeitens und der kommunikation
einige kreativschaffende zb entwickeln
neue in dem für den umgang mit der
situation
andere helfen im alltag ihre nachbarn
eine krise beschleunigt veränderungen
bringt neues hervor
vielleicht nehmen wir einiges davon als
lernerfahrung mit wenn wir wieder in den
normalzustand kommen
aber viele haben zunächst einmal große
sorgen um ihr einkommen ihre berufliche
existenz oder ihr unternehmen
wir als politikerin und politiker
bekommt derzeit viele mails briefe und
anrufe in denen die situation
geschildert wird von einzelnen
bürgerinnen und bürgern von kleinen
betrieben von verbänden die verketten
sind unterbrochen läden und restaurants
geschlossen aufträge werden storniert
meine damen und herren in dieser
situation tun wir als bundesregierung
alles nötige und alles mögliche um die
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen folgen der
krisenbewältigung abzumildern
dafür gibt es kein drehbuch gibt keinen
vorgefertigten plan den wir jetzt
einfach folgen können in unglaublich
kurzer zeit müssen fast alle bereiche
unserer gesellschaft und wirtschaft in
den blick genommen werden und kluge
antworten entwickelt wenn sich immer
wieder neue fragen stellen im
bundeskabinett haben wir am montag ein
großes kapitel ein großes programm zur
krisenbewältigung geschlossen und man
dank gilt daher sicher stellvertretend
für die mitglieder der bundesregierung
den landesregierung und den mitgliedern
des deutschen bundestages
ich möchte ihnen dafür danken dass sie
bereit sind dieses paket unter großem
zeitdruck zu verhandeln und später auch
zu beschließen
schönen dank dafür
es geht jetzt aktuell und drei
wesentliche aufgaben wir müssen erstens
eine gute gesundheitsversorgung von
corona erkrankten sicherstellen und
dafür sorgen dass alle die geschützt
sind die sie behandeln wir müssen
zweitens den lebensunterhalt der
bürgerinnen und bürger sichern die von
der krise betroffen sind und wir müssen
drittens unsere wirtschaft stabilisieren
und die arbeitsplätze erhalten und das
machen wir mit einer enormen summe geld
sehr schnell und möglichst zielgenau mit
verschiedenen maßnahmen erstens ganz
vorne steht der gesund der gesundheit
geht der schutz der gesundheit
wir helfen den frauen und männern in den
krankenhäusern und laboren und stellen
sicher dass unsere gesundheitsversorgung
den herausforderung gewachsen ist mit
jetzt noch mal dreieinhalb milliarden
euro mit der beschaffung von
schutzausrüstung und der entwicklung von
impfstoffen und weiter ausgebaut werden
wir wollen die zahl der intensivbetten
in deutschland immerhin 28.000
verdoppeln
niemand soll sich unnötige sorgen um
seine wohnung und sein lebensunterhalt
machen
wir haben in deutschland ein sehr gut
funktionierende grundsicherung die genau
das gewährleistet und wer derzeit
vorübergehend kein einkommen hat zum
beispiel als selbstständiger sollte
diese grundsicherung nutzen
wir erleichtern den zugang indem wir
prinzipien außer kraft setzen wir den
vermittlungs vorrang die
vermögensprüfung oder die prüfung der
angemessenheit sowohl aus dem
vereinfachen wir die auszahlung des
kinderzuschlages damit auch familien die
plötzlich weniger geld haben gut zurecht
kommen können und eine weitere hilfe ist
dass wir im rahmen des infektionsschutz
es auch regelung treffen was passiert
wenn keine einkommenssicherung mehr
vorhanden dass man aber die kinder zu
hause betreuen muss und das alles
sichern wir rechtlich ab wer wegen der
korona krise seine wohnungsmieten
zurzeit nicht zahlen kann
dem darf jetzt nicht gekündigt werden
wir sind als gesetzgeber und als
regierung verpflichtet den bürgerinnen
bürger in dieser situation beizustehen
und drittens stabilisieren wir die
wirtschaft
es geht um die sicherung von
arbeitsplätzen wir haben uns jetzt auf
die maßnahmen konzentriert die passgenau
sind und ganz schnell wirken können und
deshalb haben wir zum beispiel nach
ersten schritt darum sie auch die
entsprechenden gesetze schnell mit
beschlossen die regelung zum
kurzarbeitergeld geändert das instrument
das uns schon in der letzten krise
geholfen hat wir besorgen den
unternehmen liquidität wir haben eine
steuer vor zugluft geschafft indem
steuervorauszahlungen verringerten
zinsfrei gestundet werden können
außerdem haben wir die kreditprogramme
der kaffee dramatisch ausgeweitet und
wir merken auch das funktioniert jetzt
es sind tausende anträge gestellt viele
sind auch schon bewilligt und ob trotz
aller schwierigkeiten die man immer mal
zurückgemeldet bekommt jetzt sind alle
dran damit das auch klappt damit den
unternehmen nicht die puste ausgeht
und wir haben damit selbstständigen
kleinstbetriebe die den umsatzverlust
nicht wieder reinholen können auch durch
diese krise kommt ein programm für solo
selbstständige und kleinunternehmer
aufgelegt es geht um gastronomen zum
beispiel die ihr geschäft nicht mehr
aufmachen können aber die miete weiter
zahlen müssen und für die kleinen
betriebe gibt es zuschüsse bis zu 15.000
euro das programm werden wir mit den
ländern zusammen auf den weg bringen
damit es unbürokratisch umgesetzt werden
kann und schnell meine damen und herren
auch hier ergänzen wir kredite und
zuschüsse durch rechtssicherheit
niemand soll weil er jetzt in
zahlungsschwierigkeiten geraten ist
sofort insolvenz anmelden müssen und
darüber hinaus schaffen wir für die
meisten meist größeren unternehmen mit
dem finanzmarktstabilisierungsfonds
gesetzt sind wir jetzt zu einem
wirtschafts stabilisierungsfonds umbauen
die grundlage dafür dass wir sie mit
eigenkapital in dieser krise
unterstützen können auch das ist ein
ganz massives stabilitäts signal
und wer gehört und gelesen hat wie das
in deutschland und der welt aufgenommen
worden ist der weiß das war ein
wichtiges und notwendiges zeichen
meine damen und herren bund und länder
können diese aufgaben nicht aus dem
laufenden haushalt und auch nicht aus
den rücklagen finanzieren und deshalb
bringen wir heute einen
nachtragshaushalt 1 in den deutschen
bundestag der eine nettokreditaufnahme
von 156 milliarden euro vorsieht
das ist eine gigantische summe fast die
hälfte unseres normalen haushalts für
ein jahr
und weil das so eine große summe ist
muss der bundestag heute die
entscheidung treffen ob er die dafür
vorgesehen der ausnahme von der
schuldenregel des grundgesetzes im fall
einer außergewöhnlichen notsituationen
nutzt
ich bitte sie heute im namen der
bundesregierung das zu tun denn wir
brauchen das geld um uns mit aller kraft
gegen die sozialen und wirtschaftlichen
folgen der krise stemmen zu können und
wir setzen auf ihre unterstützung
meine damen und herren wir können uns
das leisten
deutschland genießt höchste bonität an
den finanzmärkten und zwar auch weil wir
in den letzten jahren sehr solide
gewirtschaftet haben vorausschauend
gearbeitet haben und einen niedrigen
schuldenstand haben es ist wichtig dass
jetzt unsere hilfen schnell dort
ankommen wo sie gebraucht werden
das ist der beitrag den wir als staat
leisten können aber er wäre nicht
wirksam wenn nicht viele bürgerinnen und
bürger mit höchstem einsatz ihren
beitrag leisten
darum gilt unser dank allen ärzten und
pflegerinnen den verkäuferinnen und
busfahren und vielen vielen anderen mehr
sie leisten groß ist in diesem tag
[Musik]
und vieles von dem was bund und ländern
beschließen was wir hier diesen tagen
beschließen werden kann nur umgesetzt
werden wenn funktionsfähige staatliche
strukturen existieren
daher gilt der dank auch den
mitarbeitern in den arbeitsagenturen den
jobcentern in den gesundheitsämtern und
polizistinnen und polizisten und auch
dort viele mitglieder nominiert
[Musik]
nochmal vor uns liegen harte wochen wir
können sie bewältigen wenn wir
solidarisch sind
darum kümmert sich die bundesregierung
um den kampf gegen das virus um die
wirtschaftlichen rahmenbedingungen um
die grundlagen unserer freien
gesellschaft aber es braucht mehr als
die regierung
wir alle müssen uns umeinander kümmern
dann kommen wir da durch
doch der vizekanzler scholz der die
kanzlerin vertrieb wie wir in häuslicher
quarantäne ist nicht weil sie krank ist
sondern weil ein arzt der sie geimpft
hat corona infiziert ist
niemand werde alleine gelassen so das
versprechen nächster redner ist
alexander gauland fraktionsvorsitzender
der fdp erst einmal die
regierungspolitik enthält viele
einsichten die wir für richtig halten
die wir teilen
man kann also die grenzen schützen und
wir werden die regierung bei gelegenheit
da erinnern in der krise schaut die
nation auf den demokratischen
nationalstaat und dessen
handlungsfähigkeit europäische
zusammenarbeit kann sie ergänzen aber
nicht ersetzen
das heißt auch deutsche interessen
müssen wahrgenommen werden wie es die
regierung im falle des versuchs eine
deutsche firma amerikanischer kontrolle
zu unterwerfen
richtigerweise getan können
[Applaus]
zusammen stehen ist jetzt erste
bürgerpflicht deshalb werden wir auch
den finanziellen maßnahmen und
gesetzlichen änderungen weitgehend
zustimmen wenn diese temporär angelegt
und auf die dauer der korona notlage
beschränkt bleiben
die abdankung des parlaments auf zeit
wollen wir allerdings nicht einzuhalten
wird der kollege bürger vortragen
meine damen und herren diese zustimmung
bedeutet allerdings nicht dass wir uns
nicht vorbehalten abklingen der krise
die zu beginn gemachten fehler der
regierung zu benennen und in diesem
hause zu diskutieren einreisekontrollen
kamen zu spät und die bevorratung von
schutzmasken mit einweghandschuhen waren
offensichtlich ungenügend ich zitiere
als pars pro toto den vorsitzenden der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung hamburg
er beklagt dass die schutzausrüstung für
ärzte in der hansestadt knapp werden
zitat wir versuchen seit wochen
verzweifelt irgendwo auf der welt
schutzausrüstung zu kaufen
das ist fast nicht möglich die
bundesregierung habe versprochen zu
helfen aber das nichts gekommen nicht
eine einzige maske haben wir gekriegt
zitat ende
da beim entweder man hat das robert koch
institut im jahre 2012 ein detailliertes
katastrophenszenario vorgelegt über das
die bundesregierung das parlament dieses
haus im jahre 2013 ausführlich
unterrichtet hatte damit wird eine
pandemie mit einem satz wie roh aus
asien durchgespielt dass nach
deutschland kommt ich zitiere die
symptome sind fieber und trockener
husten die mehrzahl der patienten als
atem nur den röntgenaufnahmen sichtbare
veränderungen in der lunge heißt es in
dem papier
kinder und jugendliche haben in der
regel leichtere krankheitsverläufe mit
letalität von rund einem prozent werden
die letalität bei über 65-jährigen bei
50 prozent liegt
das ist in diesem hause diskutiert
worden das ist die exakte beschreibung
der folgen des kombi 19
das krisenszenario war seit 2012 bekannt
das papier prognostizierte aber tausende
tote warum gab es keine ausreichenden
vorsorgemaßnahmen doch meine damen und
herren es kommt ich weiß es auch jetzt
weniger auf die vergangenheit als auf
die zukunft an
und da vermissen wir einen plan der
bundesregierung herr minister für die
zeit in drei monaten die gewaltige
anstrengungen die sich auf insgesamt
mehr als 700 milliarden euro beläuft und
alles zusammennimmt ist unbegrenzt so
wenig durchzuhalten
wie der shutdown einer ganzen
gesellschaft über das jetzt erlassene
kontaktverbot hinaus bleiben dann nur
noch ausgangssperren auch wenn ein
süddeutscher ministerpräsident der sich
ein wenig wie ein roh konsul aufführt
solche gern hätte müssen heute schon die
sozialen folgen bedacht werden es ergibt
keinen sinn die anzahl der korona toten
auf kosten möglicher suizid auch vor zu
senken
was also ist der masterplan der
bundesregierung
was wird sie den menschen sagen wenn es
sind drei monaten auch immer keine
entwarnung gibt der minister welche
alternativen gibt es zu den jetzigen
kurs und wann gedenkt die
bundesregierung diese aufzuzeigen
meine damen und herren die menschen
haben angst zu recht um ihnen diese
angst zu nehmen bedarf es mehr als geld
nämlich einer strategie die über die
nächsten zwei drei monate hinaus weist
ich bedanke
[Applaus]
ungewohnt moderate töne des
fdp-fraktionsvorsitzenden man werde den
hilfspaketen zustimmen das ja aber die
regierung hätte früher vorsorge treffen
müssen zudem fehle ein plan eine
strategie für die zeit danach nächster
redner ist ralph brinkhaus vorsitzender
der unionsfraktion die menschen in
deutschland wachsen momentan über sich
hinaus im gesundheitswesen wir haben
darüber gesprochen in vielen lokalen
krisenstäben wo die gleiche arbeit
geleistet wird wie im bundesregierung
und im landesregierung bereich feuerwehr
polizei rettungswesen und in vielen
vielen fällen auch im bereich der
logistik des einzelhandels es gibt viele
viele menschen die dieses land am laufen
halten und was besonders berührend ist
meine damen und herren ist die
unglaubliche solidarität in
nachbarschaften im familien den
freundeskreisen wo man füreinander
einkauf wo man sich umeinander kümmert
wo man sich gegenseitig hilft und meine
damen und herren das macht mich sehr
stolz und das kannten sehr stolz auf
dieses land machen aber
es sind auch dunkle tage sind dunkle
tage für die menschen die ihre
angehörigen verloren haben den unser
mitgefühl gilt für die menschen die
krank sind und auf genesung hoffen
und übrigens nicht nur in deutschland
ist eine schreckliche bilder die uns
ganz aus der nähe aus italien aus
spanien erreichen und es sind auch
dunkle tage für diejenige die sich
sorgen machen um ihre existenz um ihren
arbeitsplatz und das was sie sich in
jahren aufgebaut haben und unglaublich
viele mails und anrufe erreichen jeden
von uns meine damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen hier stehen
wahrscheinlich vor der größten
herausforderung in der 71 jährigen
geschichte unserer bundesrepublik
deutschland eine herausforderung die wir
so noch nicht gehabt haben und die auch
deswegen einmalig ist weil sich niemand
niemand in diesem land dieser
herausforderung entziehen kann
sie betrifft wirklich jeden vom ganz
klein über den großen vom alten vom
schwachen und vom starken meine damen
und herren
und diese herausforderung die haben wir
uns sicherlich nicht gewünscht aber wir
werden sie annehmen und das ist das
versprechen wir werden kämpfen
wir werden kämpfen wir werden kämpfen um
unsere gesundheit insbesondere um die
gesundheit der alten und schwachen
wir werden kämpfen und unsere
arbeitsplätze unsere
wirtschaftsstrukturen ja und wir werden
auch kämpfen um den zusammenhalt in
unserer gesellschaft dass er in dieser
krise auch erhalten bleibt und wir
werden kämpfen um den zusammenhalt und
darüber müssen wir auch reden in europa
das sich jeder sein eigenes ding macht
dass wir zusammen lösungen entwickeln
neue landschaft
und jeder von uns wird kämpfen
das fängt bei der bundeskanzlerin an die
das momentan vom home office aus macht
das geht über den krankenpfleger die
krankenpflegerin im gesundheitswesen
weiter
und das hört bei den ganz kleinen auf
bei den erstklässlern die momentan ihren
unterrichtsstoff mit ihren eltern zu
hause nachholen und wir werden in dieser
krise liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
auch entscheiden und da stimmst du was
man in einer krise machen kann ist sich
wegzuducken und ist nichts zu tun zu
warten bis der sturm vorüber geht
aber diese entscheidung sind
entscheidungen unter unsicherheit wir
wissen nicht ob wir jetzt alles richtig
entscheidende und der finanzminister hat
gesagt wir können es auch nicht wissen
weil wir das alles das erste mal machen
aber genau das meine damen und herren
ist politische führung der mut zu haben
entscheidungen zu treffen und demut zu
haben auch fehler zu machen denn das ist
besser als jetzt nichts zu tun und genau
deswegen werden wir hier heute als
solcher bundestag ein einmaliges paket
verabschieden weil jetzt die zeit des
handelns ist meine damen und herren und
handeln
handeln heißt dass wir ein
gesundheitspaket auf den weg bringen wo
es auch darum geht kliniken zu schützen
wo es darum geht bessere werkzeuge zu
haben im kampf gegen die infektion es
geht darum wirtschaft und arbeitsplätze
zu sichern die großen strukturen zu
sichern mit einem rettungsschirm aber
auch die kleinen zu unterstützen die
momentan in einer besonders harten
situation sind es geht darum das
arbeitsrecht so zu ändern dass
landwirtschaft gesundheitswesen logistik
auch weiter möglich ist aber es geht
darum auch soziale härten abzufedern
für mieter aber auch für vermieter und
deswegen haben wir uns so eine mühe
gegeben das ganze auch abgewogen zu
gestalten
es geht darum vereinfachten
unbürokratischen zugang zu den sozialen
sicherungssystemen zu gewährleisten
und es geht um viele andere dinge mehr
und das werden wir heute als dieses
parlament sehr sehr schnell beschließen
und was wir auch beschließen werden ist
dass wir all das auch mit
haushalterischen mitteln unterlegen ja
156 milliarden euro
das ist unglaublich viel wer hätte das
gedacht dass wir darüber sprechen werden
ja ein bürgschafts garantie volumen von
über 1 billion euro ist enorm und das
sind keine einfachen entscheidungen die
wir treffen aber richtig ist auch wenn
es sich ein land leisten kann dann ist
es unseres land weil wir auch vernünftig
gewirtschaftet am altarm und hören und
deswegen werden wir das jetzt auf
einsetzen was wir uns erwirtschaftet
haben weil dafür macht man
haushaltspolitik dass man auch in der
not das entsprechende geld hat um die
entsprechende maßnahmen zu treffen und
wir werden meine damen und herren das
ganze in einem sehr schnellen verfahren
machen und ich muss mich und ich darf
mich ausdrücklich bedanken auch bei der
opposition die auf beratungs rechte die
auf fristen verzichtet hat und die
gesagt hat 'jetzt ist es wichtiger dass
wir lösungen für dieses land kriegen das
ist nicht selbstverständlich herzlichen
dank dafür
wir werden in diesem paket auch in
freiheitsrechte eingreifen
wir werden in eigentumsrechte eingreifen
wir werden wie gesagt in haushaltsregeln
eingreifen
und deswegen ist es richtig dass all das
was wir tun so weit es eben möglich auch
befristet ist und es kann auch keine
selbstverständlichkeit sein als
parlament in diesem verfahren
entsprechend so weiter zu machen
deswegen ist es auch richtig dass wir
uns heute mit unserer geschäftsordnung
beschäftigen damit wir auch in der krise
schnell handlungsfähig sind und damit
parlamentarische verfahren auch in der
krise ordentlich und weiter möglich sind
war unter und wir werden all das was wir
jetzt beschließen wenn die pandemie
vorbei ist auf dem prüfstand stellen
selbstverständlich und wir werden
selbstverständlich auch auf den
prüfstand stellt ob das alles was wir
gemacht haben richtig ist wir werden auf
den prüfstand stellen ob das
zusammenspiel auf den föderalen ebenen
richtig ist und wir werden auf den
prüfstand stellen wie wir uns noch
besser auf solche situationen
entsprechend vorbereiten können das ist
selbstverständlich meine damen und
herren und eins kann ich ihnen auch
sagen es wird wahrscheinlich nicht das
letzte paket sollen was wir hier
beschließen werden
und eins ist auch richtig da brauchen
wir uns auch überhaupt nichts vormachen
gesetze und geld sind das eine aber das
andere ist dass wir es auch umsetzen
müssen dass dieses geld herr
finanzminister jetzt auch schnell fließt
dass die rettungsschirme schnell einen
staat kommen dass der zugang zu den
sozialsystemen dann auch ohne bürokratie
entsprechend möglich ist es muss auch
mehr gemacht werden und das ist richtig
im bereich der medizinischen
schutzausrüstung beatmungsgeräte in der
unterstützung unseres gesundheitssystems
wenn der heutige tag vorbei ist dann
beginnt die umsetzung sofern sie nicht
in den letzten wochen schon begonnen hat
umsetzung ist jetzt das was sind meine
damen und ja
[Applaus]
aber all das staatliche handeln kann nur
funktionieren wenn tatsächlich alle auch
mitmachen
wir würden gerne jeden so stellen als
werden diese corona krise nicht
stattgefunden hat das ist überhaupt
keine frage aber das wird nicht gehen
das wird auch die fähigkeit dieses
staates überfordern und deswegen müssen
wir uns auf ihn beschränken die es aus
eigenen kräften nicht schaffen können
durch diese krise durch zu kommen
wir werden das in vielen vielen
bereichen hinkommen vielleicht nicht in
allen aber das ist unsere anstrengung
die wir jetzt entsprechend vornehmen
werden und dafür bedarf es auch den
einsatz von fehler und es gibt
großartige beispiel es gibt großartige
beispiele von textilunternehmen die auf
massenproduktion umstellen von
spirituosenherstellern die jetzt
desinfektionsmittel herstellen es gibt
meiner lokalzeitung ein beispiel da hat
jemand seinen friseursalon dena
vermietet hat gesagt mensch wir müssen
zusammenhalten nächsten monate keine
miete
es gibt aber und das muss man auch sagen
leider schlechte beispiel die uns
erreichen auch briefe von zulieferern
und lieferanten die sagen meine kunden
geben jetzt der druck an uns weiter und
wir müssen das alleine bewältigen
ich kann nur dazu aufrufen wir müssen
jetzt alle solidarisch sein sonst wird
diese krise nicht überstanden werden
meine damen und herren
man sagt man sagt in der krise kommt das
gute und schlechte des menschen wie
unter einem brennglas zutage was ich
momentan sehe ist ganz ganz viel gutes
ganz viel solidarität ganz viel hilfe
ganz viel gemeinsam
was sich auch sehe ist dass wir in
dieser krise erkennen was eigentlich
wirklich wichtig ist dass man seine
eltern und großeltern besuchen kann dass
man sich mit freunden treffen kann dass
man überall hingehen kann wo man
hingehen möchte dass meine sicherheit
hat und vom arbeitsplatz und ich glaube
mal wir beginnen langsam wieder zu
begreifen
was die wirklich wichtigen dinge im
leben sind meine damen und herren
und wir können ihnen hier von dieser
stelle nicht versprechen
wie lange diese krise dauert wir können
wenig versprechen welche opfer und
einschränkungen wir noch tragen müssen
und wir können auch nicht versprechen
dass jeder existenz jeder arbeitsplatz
und alles so erhalten bleibt wie es ist
aber wenn wir in den nächsten wochen
zusammen halten wenn wir gemeinsam
kämpfen wenn wir solidarisch sind dann
glaube ich nicht nähern
ich bin davon überzeugt dass genau dann
unser land deutschland nach bewohner ein
besseres land sein wird
dankeschön
nächster redner ist der vorsitzende fdp
fraktion christian lindner
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen drei wochen liegt die
regierungserklärung zur krone krise
zurück seitdem hat sich die lage
dynamisch entwickelt experten haben mehr
als einmal ihre einschätzung korrigiert
wir sehen es hier im plenum dass sich
die lage dramatisch verändert hat wir
nehmen es der tatsache dass die
regierungschefin selbst sich in
häuslicher quarantäne befindet wenn
gesundheit und freiheit gleichermaßen
gefährdet sind dann lernt man neue ihren
wert kennen unsere guten wünsche gelten
jetzt frau merkel den kolleginnen und
kollegen dieses hauses die infiziert
sind oder in quarantäne sich befinden
müssen und vor allen dingen allen
menschen im land die betroffen sind
unser dank gilt all denen die jetzt in
diesen tagen mehr tun als nur ihre
pflicht in krankenhäusern aber auch bei
der polizei bis an die supermarktkasse
jetzt erfahren die menschen den respekt
und die aufmerksamkeit die ihnen auch in
gewöhnlichen zeiten hätten zuteil werden
sollen das öffentliche und das
wirtschaftliche leben sind runter
gefahren um die ausbreitung von corona
einzudämmen und zu bremsen
manche haben zweifel beim jetzigen
wissensstand wären aber die alternativen
riskant es geht um menschen
wer denkt bei den bildern aus italien
nicht an die eigene familie
ich denke nicht an statistische größen
sondern an meine omas und deshalb sind
die aktuellen freiheits einschränkungen
verhältnismäßig der aktuelle zustand
widerspricht aber der menschlichen natur
er passt nicht zu den werten einer
offenen gesellschaft
er ist eine gefahr für den sozialen
frieden wenn schon in der allernächsten
zeit die akzeptanz der menschen sinken
könnte er ist eine gefahr für unser
wirtschaftliches leben weil irgendwann
der ökonomische schaden ihrer parabel
sein könnte mit dem heutigen tag muss es
deshalb darum gehen diesen zustand
schritt für schritt aber so schnell wie
möglich zu überwinden
von der ertüchtigung des
gesundheitswesens über die
bereitstellung von flächen deckenden
tests auf corona muss nun die regierung
müssen die behörden
in ländern und kommunen alles
unternehmen damit die menschen
schnellstmöglich in die freiheit
zurückkehren können heute berät und
beschließt der deutsche bundestag über
ein paket zur abfederung der
wirtschaftlichen folgen
regierung und opposition tragen in
diesen zeiten eine gemeinsame
staatspolitische verantwortung
diejenigen die im deutschen bundestag
die oppositionsrolle wahrnehmen tragen
in den ländern und auf der örtlichen
ebene auch exekutive verantwortung und
deshalb haben wir intensiv beraten und
ich will der bundesregierung und den die
regierung tragenden fraktionen
ausdrücklich für das konstruktive klima
danken indem wir miteinander über das
was heute zu entscheiden ist gesprochen
haben aspekt da haben wir beitragen
können aspekte die uns wichtig sind
haben eingang in die beschlussvorlage
gefunden beispielsweise dass die
schwelle zur stabilisierung von
unternehmen nicht bei 2.000
beschäftigten sondern über 250 liegt das
grundrechtseingriffe wie etwa das
auslesen von mobilfunkdaten nicht
hopplahopp in dieser krise beschlossen
wird sondern sorgsam ort zu einem
späteren zeitpunkt noch einmal
besprochen werden kann dass die
befugnisse des infektionsschutzgesetzes
die den bund neu zu wachsen zeitlich
befristet sind so dass auch in ruhigeren
zeiten
diese frage neu aufgeworfen werden
können manches dennoch missfällt uns das
neue leistungs verweigerungsrecht und
die veränderungen im mietrecht verlagern
einseitig belastungen hier hätten wir
uns alternativen wir an sonder wohngeld
gewünscht wir hätten auch an anderen
stellen
das paket der großen koalition
modifiziert aber darum geht es jetzt
nicht
bei allen unterschieden in der
einschätzung und zusätzlichen
wünschenswerten maßnahmen geht es jetzt
darum nicht wir sind gemeinsam als
fraktionen doch durch ein ziel verbunden
nämlich schaden vom deutschen volk und
der bevölkerung abzuwenden und deshalb
werden wir trotz aller bedenken im
detail den beschluss vorlagen der
regierung heute zustimmen
jetzt ist die stunde des staates
wir brauchen ihn bei allem was über die
fähigkeit individuelle verantwortung zu
übernehmen hinausgeht genau einer
situation befinden wir uns jetzt wo wir
die staatlichen möglichkeiten alles was
er fiskalisch in die waagschale werfen
kann nutzen müssen aber auch seine
möglichkeiten sind grenzt
wir nutzen jetzt das was wir an
fähigkeiten haben aber auf dauer wird
auch der starke deutsche staat nicht in
der lage sein eine volkswirtschaft zu
stabilisieren die nicht ins leben
zurückfindet irgendwann wird auch jemand
dafür zahlen müssen was wir jetzt an
schutzschirm aufspannen und deshalb
werden wir in der zeit nach der krise
auch über die weitere finanzplanung und
die vorhaben der regierung neu sprechen
müssen
ich erwarte eine re priorisierung vieler
vorhaben denn es wird darum gehen dass
wir die langfristigen wirtschaftlichen
folgen dieser aktuellen krise nicht zu
lasten von bürgerinnen und bürgern und
nächste generationen einseitig verteilt
wir werden auch noch sprechen müssen wir
werden auch noch sprechen müssen ob die
jetzt beschlossenen maßnahmen wirklich
treffsicher sind wir sorgen uns um den
kleinen mittelstand um die betriebe
zwischen 10 und 250 beschäftigten die in
den vergangenen jahren viel von dem
abgegeben haben was sie erwirtschaftet
haben es war kollege brinkhaus nicht der
staat der gut gewirtschaftet hat es
waren die menschen es war der
mittelstand die gut gewirtschaftet haben
und deshalb sind uns möglichkeiten
zugewachsen und genau diejenigen in der
mitte der gesellschaft die so viel von
ihrer leistung abgegeben haben in den
vergangenen jahren und damit solidarisch
waren die dürfen jetzt erwarten dass die
staatliche gemeinschaft auch mit ihnen
in diesen krisenzeiten solidarisch ist
deshalb deshalb hätten wir uns gewünscht
dass die schwelle nicht bei 250 sondern
bei 50 beschäftigten liegt und ich rege
an bei den nächsten gelegenheiten in
denen wir über die modifikationen der
sicherheitsnetz zu sprechen diese frage
noch einmal miteinander aufrufen
in nordrhein westfalen um ein beispiel
zu nennen nordrhein westfalen hat die
dortige landesregierung entschieden mit
eigenen mitteln bei unternehmen auch bis
50 beschäftigte eine soforthilfe von bis
zu 25.000 euro zu zahlen
das ist eine praxis die für deutschland
insgesamt vorbildlich ist eine
entscheidung die auch die
bundesregierung hätte treffen können und
wir werden über das tempo der hilfen
sprechen müssen wir haben nichts
einzuwenden gegen die programme die über
die kfw aufgelegt werden aber wir sehen
mit sorge die administrative überlastung
bei privaten geschäftsbanken und in den
öffentlich rechtlichen strukturen
deshalb ist es
aus unserer sicht empfehlenswert dass
wir die möglichkeiten auch unserer
finanzbehörden nutzen
in guten zeiten mag sich mancher ärgern
über die leistungsfähigkeit unserer
finanzbehörden in diesen zeiten könnten
wir sie gut nutzen um unbürokratisch und
schnell über das steuerrecht
liquiditätshilfen zu gewähren und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir werden nach
der krise uns mit internationalen fragen
der zusammenarbeit in europa und darüber
hinaus beschäftigen müssen
eine debatte über neuen protektionismus
und abschottung die es ja nahezu
unvermeidlich
aber eile ist doch die schlussfolgerung
aus der korona krise eine andere das
nicht abschottung hilft das nicht die
aufgabe der internationalen
arbeitsteilung sinnvoll ist sondern im
gegenteil die eigentliche lehre ist doch
dass man eine menschheitsaufgabe
eine menschheits herausforderung wie
eine pandemie nicht im
nationalstaatlichen kontext bewältigen
kann sondern dass corona eigentlich der
anlass ist ganz neu über internationale
kooperation das lernen voneinander und
multilateralismus zu sprechen
es sind deutliche unterschiede zu
sonstigen debatten die opposition
unterstützt die hilfsmaßnahmen mit
regierung und lindner lobte die
konstruktive zusammenarbeit die
jeweilige kritik hält sich in grenzen
nächste rednerin die
fraktionsvorsitzende der linken am ihrer
mohammed ali
sehr geehrter herr präsident kolleginnen
und kollegen das hilfspaket der
bundesregierung zur bewältigung dieser
beispiellosen gravierenden krise enthält
viele gute regelung mit denen wir
einverstanden sind die gespräche wird
die wehr den letzten tagen mit der
bundesregierung dazu geführt haben die
waren sehr konstruktiv dennoch fehlen
nach wie vor wichtige regelungen die
notwendig sind um sicherzustellen dass
durch diese krise nicht viele menschen
in not geraten
und dass sich dadurch das gesicht
unseres landes nicht extrem verändert
aber auch ich möchte zunächst auf die
menschen zu sprechen kommt in dieser
krise herausragendes leisten das sind zb
die beschäftigten im gesundheitswesen im
einzelhandel die berufs
berufskraftfahrer und viele andere in
den sogenannten systemrelevanten berufen
ihnen wird in diesen tagen zu recht viel
gedankt auch hier in diesem hause
man kann auch nicht oft genug danke sie
aber aber dieser dank der sollte sich
nicht nur in worten zeigen nein hier
braucht es auch einen angemessenen
finanziellen ausgleich für die erhöhte
arbeitsbelastung für die würdigung
dieses außergewöhnlichen engagement ein
zuschlag von 500 euro pro monat für
diejenigen die eine systemrelevanten
berufen arbeiten das ist das mindeste
und es kann nicht sein dass zum beispiel
pflegerinnen und pfleger deren enorme
wichtigkeit für unsere gesellschaft uns
jetzt noch jeden tag vor augen geführt
wird dass die weiter zu hungerlöhnen
arbeiten müssen bitte sprechen sie in
entsprechende und selbstverständlich
muss ich die wertschätzung auch darin
zeigen dass diejenigen die aus
beruflichen gründen jetzt viel kontakt
für menschen haben und das sind nicht
nur erste pfleger verkäuferinnen
verkäufer da sind auch polizisten
polizisten dass diese menschen
flächendeckend mit schutzkleidung zur
verfügung also nichts wofür und das
becken denkt opern verfügung gestellt
wird dass sie bekommen hier braucht es
wirklich klare und schnell umzusetzende
konzepte wenn entsprechende priorisieren
es war ein fataler fehler das silo
gerade produktion abgebaut wurde und
dass nicht genügend bevorratet wurde
aber auch die kürzungspolitik im
gesundheitswesen das spardiktat durch
die privatisierung der letzten jahre
das war falsch gesundheit ist keine ware
das muss spätestens wirklich schwierig
jetzt gegen die ausweitung des
kurzarbeitergeldes die es richtig aber
uns muss doch auch klar sein dass viele
menschen trotzdem vor unlösbaren
problemen stehen dem ich diejenigen
denen jetzt gerade der volle lohn zum
leben ausreicht den reichen die 60
prozent lohnfortzahlung eben nicht
deswegen muss das kurzarbeitergeld auf
90 des vorjährigen lohns erhöht werden
das sicherlich nicht wesentlich besser
und auch mitbestimmungsrechte dürfen in
diesen zeiten keinesfalls geschliffen
werden das fordern zu recht auch die
gesellschaft
ein weiterer punkt der betrifft der noch
keiner nicht genug berücksichtigung
findet im paket der bundesregierung der
betrifft die ärmsten unserer
gesellschaft diejenigen die von 8 4
betroffen sind und diejenigen mit sehr
kleinen renten hilfsangebote wie die
tafeln die fehlen wie vielerorts und
nebenjobs die können nicht mehr
angetreten werden die benötigt werden
und kleine rente aufzubessern weil es
diese jobs nicht mehr gibt oder weil der
gerade ältere menschen jetzt nicht mehr
das haus verlassen dürfen
aus gesundheitlichen gründen es ist
darum notwendig hier zu helfen deswegen
stimmen sie bitte unserem antrag zu die
kleinen renten und das arbeitslosengeld
2 um 200 euro pro monat auftreten
es ist auch dringend notwendig dass den
obdachlosen menschen menschen in dieser
krise geholfen wird die jetzt noch vor
größeren schwierigkeiten stehen weil
eben hilfsangebote fehlen weil spenden
von passanten nicht mehr stattfinden
können es ist notwendig dass der bund
die kommunen jetzt mit mitteln
ausstattet um hier dringend schnelle
hilfsangebot zu schaffen ein
wesentlicher punkt über den wir heute
sprechen wir den wir abstimmen werden
ist dass trotz der schuldenbremse in
dieser notsituation schulden gemacht
werden können wir werden dem als linke
zustimmt
wir haben die schuldenbremse diese
unnötige beschränkungen der
handlungsfähigkeit des staates schon
immer für einen fehler dabei aber wir
müssen wir wissen wirklich jetzt schon
darüber reden wie diese schulden dann
zurückgezahlt werden nach der krise wenn
wir als linke wir wollen verhindern dass
die rückzahlung zu sozialabbau führt und
zu weiteren investitionsstopp wir sind
eins wir sind uns alle einig dass es in
dieser historischen krise solidarität
verlangt und große teile der
gesellschaft die leben sie jetzt ja auch
vor
die einen verzichten darauf konzert
karten zurückzugeben
die anderen spenden lebensmittel oder
kleidung für bedürftige gehen für ältere
menschen die nach
aber schafft einkauf und das war es an
so vielen stellen im kleinen gilt das
muss auch in großen geschehen
es gibt in unserer gesellschaft einige
mit sehr starken schultern mit riesigen
vermögen wir fordern eine sonderabgabe
für multimillionäre und milliardäre
damit sie einen gerechten beitrag zur
bewältigung dieser historischen krise
meistern und wenn der staat jetzt
richtigerweise auch unternehmen mit
einsteigt um sie zu stützen um
arbeitsplätze zu sichern
dann muss bereits jetzt klar sein dass
nach dieser krise unternehmensgewinne
dann wieder fließen das davon dann bitte
auch der staat profitiert das viel zu
oft geltende prinzip dass gewinne
privatisiert aber schulden die
allgemeinheit tragen müssen dass dieses
prinzip dafür nicht gelten kollegin und
eine einsparung die dringend vorgenommen
werden muss ist eine einsparung im
militär etat ist viel zu hoch und in
diesen zeiten weiter um 2% rüstungs die
renato festzuhalten
es war und ich möchte hier auch
ausdrücklich antonio guterres dem
generalsekretär der vereinten nationen
zu stimmen der anfang dieser woche einen
weltweiten waffenstillstand gefordert
hat im angesicht dieser pandemie wenn
deutschland darf zum einen beitrag
leisten will dann müssen
selbstverständlich sofort alle
waffenexporte gestoppt und außerdem
dürfen wir die menschen die aus krieg
und elend geflohen sind
die jetzt auf den griechischen inseln
ausharren müssen an der griechischen
grenze
die dürfen in dieser krise nicht
vergessen werden und dazu gehört eben
auch dass die bundesregierung ihre
zusagen nicht vergisst die
minderjährigen flüchtlinge aufzunehmen
wir stellen heute wichtige weichen nicht
nur dafür dass während dieser krise
geschieht sondern auch dafür wie dieses
land nach der krise aussehen wird es
gibt großen unternehmen die sehr stark
sind die über die große rücklagen
verfügen
sie werden diese krise teilweise auch
mit staatlicher
überstehen und dann gibt es die anderen
designerinnen und die mittelständischen
unternehmen die diese rücklagen nicht
haben und ja das hilfspaket das enthält
kredithilfen teilweise auch
direktzahlung das sind alles richtige
schritte die wir unterstützen aber für
viele sind diese direktzahlungen leider
nur tropfen auf heiße steine und die
möglichkeit kredite aufzunehmen
die kommt für viele kleine und
mittelständische mittelständischen
unternehmen für handwerksbetriebe für
solo selbstständige aber auch für
künstlerinnen und künstler nicht in
frage weil kredite zurückgezahlt werden
müssen und das ist nicht möglich
die menschen brauchen viel umfassende
hilfe und zwar schnell und
unbürokratisch nur so kann verhindert
werden dass durch diese krise die
weitere monopolisierung der märkte
die verdrängung kleinerer und mittlerer
unternehmen durch wenige großkonzerne
exponentiell vorangetrieben wird wir
müssen alles tun um die vielfalt zu
erhalten
auch die vielfalt der kunst und der
kultur in diese vielfalt macht uns aus
ist der größte reicht von lidl in diesen
zeiten tragen nicht nur die
öffentlich-rechtlichen medien sondern
auch viele private lokale medien eine
große verantwortung die regionalzeitung
die lokalen tv und radiosender
sie sind wichtiger denn je sie
informieren vor ort sie klären auf und
sie bilden ein wichtiges gegengewicht
gegen so manche falsche information aus
dem internet sie brauchen jetzt hilfe
weil überlebenswichtige werbe einnahmen
wegbrechen und das gleiche gilt auch für
freie journalistin journalisten die
jetzt ohne aufträge da sind wenn wir der
freien presse helfen unterstützen wir
unsere demokratie
die notwendige einbindung der pandemie
die erfordert derzeit einschränkung von
grundrechten wie wir es uns vor zwei
wochen noch nicht vorstellen konnten es
ist jetzt auch die zeit in der sich
demokratie bewähren muss und deshalb ist
es auch die stunde in der wir darauf
achten müssen dass nicht durch die
hintertür grund und freiheitsrechte
dauerhaft ausgehöhlt und eingeschränkte
hier wird die linke nicht mit
wir werden nicht zustimmen wenn es zum
beispiel mit handy tracking geht oder um
eine dauerhafte beschneidung von
versammlungsrecht wir werden nicht
zulassen dass parlamentarischen
mitbestimmungsrechte ausgehebelt werden
unser land das darf nach dieser krise
keinesfalls weniger demokratisch und
freiheitlich sei für die regierung auch
von den linken aber das maßnahmenpaket
reiche noch nicht sie fordern zum
beispiel einen zuschlag von 500 euro für
pfleger und pflegerinnen sowie eine
aufstockung des kurzarbeitergeldes
nächste rednerin ist katrin göring
eckardt fraktionsvorsitzende von bündnis
90 grüne
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen typ erfurt life ist eine gruppe
aus allen möglichen auf allen möglichen
plattformen gegründet von einem
opernsänger buchhandlungen blumenläden
reisebüros die brauerei sind dabei die
stadt steht still
aber der comic laden fertigware aus das
bier kommt vom heimathafen nach hause
die großmutter bekommt nicht nur einen
podcast sondern auch blumen es gibt
bücher to go studis organisieren die
einkäufe per lastenrad in mühlhausen
bekommt man torten und bücher
gleichzeitig die bürgerinnen und bürger
dieses landes und das passiert in zig
städten in dieser republik gerade
spannen ihren kleinen privaten
rettungsschirm
neben unternehmungen kaufen ein bild
reservieren konzertkarten für später
dass es das großartige was uns als land
in diesen tagen ausmacht
lange lange waren lange war unser land
nicht zu sehr geprägt von einsamkeit und
isolation und zugleich von gemeinsinn
und fürsorge und natürlich von dem einen
thema eine familie verordnet sich beim
essen nicht mehr über corona zu reden
kinder erleben ihre eltern als lehrerin
einer fällt schon die decke nach drei
tagen home office auf den kopf ein
großer sportvereinen gibt jeden tag
turnstunden für kinder
herzlichen dank übrigens auch im namen
meiner enkel menschen rücken auseinander
und zusammen gegen die heute sind wir
hier
politikerinnen und politiker manche im
saal andere draußen und wir wollen genau
das tun einen rettungsschirm spannen
wir haben in den letzten tagen viel
darüber diskutiert wie das geht
wir sorgen uns um menschen unternehmen
wir sollten uns über freiheits und
bürgerrechte und wir fragen uns was ist
jetzt wirklich verhältnismäßig wir
fragen geologin und verfassungsrechtlern
hausärzte und hausärztinnen
vorstandsvorsitzende betriebsrätinnen
gastronomen friseure feuerwehrfrau wir
fragen weil wir noch nicht überall alle
antworten haben für die nächste zeit in
dieser krise und ich finde wir sollten
das auch so ehrlich sagen wir werden
fehler machen
ich hoffe wir werden
wir machen das hier so weit es geht
zusammen denn es geht um vertrauen
vertrauen in einen handlungsfähigen
staat der keine und keinen vergisst
vertrauen übrigens in einem starken
staat der nicht national handelt sondern
europäisch und global meine damen und
herren noch am anfang zeichnet die krise
bereits bereits viele dunkle schatten in
der autoindustrie stehen die bänder
still
tourismus luftfahrt kleine läden hotels
und kneipen bangen um ihre existenz
für viele heißt dass kurzarbeit
arbeitslosigkeit weniger geld ja
deutlich weniger theater und kinos haben
geschlossen und müssen trotzdem laufende
kosten bedienen alles das wissen wir
künstlerinnen und künstler
kulturbetriebe ohne aufträge versuchen
ohne nennenswerte wir zurücklagen über
die runden zu kommen gut dass wir ihnen
helfen ein musiker freute sich dieser
tage um 100 euro spende für einen online
konzert 12.000 euro sind im gerade
weggebrochen landwirte bangen um aussaat
und ernte weil die helferinnen und
helfer fehlen und schon jetzt ist klar
diese krise berührt uns alle das ist
eine außergewöhnliche notsituation und
deshalb müssen unsere antworten
außergewöhnlich sein und hören für uns
ist klar in dieser zeit stets
kooperationen vor konkurrenz
zusammenarbeit per brinkhaus ich gebe
diesen dank zurück das war wirklich ein
konstruktives miteinander in den letzten
tagen demokratische opposition und
regierung
ja meistens natürlich meistens wir haben
nicht alles erreicht das ist mit
sicherheit zu klar
und trotzdem haben sich alle darum
bemüht dass das gelingt für uns als
bündnis 90 die grünen will ich
ausdrücklich sagen es ist zeit
verantwortung zu übernehmen damit
niemand allein und niemand
zurückgelassen wird und deswegen bringt
der bundestag heute dieses paket auf den
weg zu helfen zu schützen zu entlasten
das gesundheitssystem zu stärken
der umfang und die einmaligkeit sind ja
notlage entsprechend und deswegen
stimmen wir übrigens nicht weil es um
mehrheiten geht sondern voller
überzeugung dafür dass wir die
ausnahmeregelung der schuldenbremse
heute hier aktivieren meine damit
natürlich nicht dass eine reihe unserer
vorschläge aufgenommen worden die
entschädigung von familien die wegen
fehlender kinderbetreuung zu hause nicht
richtig arbeiten können
der schutzschirm für soziale träger der
rettungsfonds für künstlerinnen und
kulturschaffende für solo selbstständige
das sind einige beispiele natürlich ist
nicht alles schon perfekt aber ich
verspreche wir werden weiter danach
schauen was funktioniert und wo es
weiter hilfe braucht natürlich bedauere
ich dass die bundesregierung unseren
vorschlag einen bonus zu zahlen für das
medizinische pflegepersonal nicht
aufgegriffen hat diese heldinnen und
helden verdienen natürlich den beifall
auf den balkonen aber sie verdienen eben
auch direkte unterstützung und gute
bezahlung gerade in diesen zeiten und
ich weiß ich weiß das ist
mindestens genauso sehr darum geht dass
sie ihre arbeit gut machen können das
desinfektionsmittel handschuhe
mundschutz kleidung da sind und ich weiß
auch dass alle erdenklichen bemühungen
laufen das bereit zu stellen und
trotzdem ist die sorge groß
und schließlich sollten wir die nicht
aus dem blick verlieren die am
allerwenigsten haben wenn das
kostenfreie mittagessen in kita und
schule wegfällt wenn die meisten tafeln
schließen mussten dann mache ich mir
wirklich große sorgen und es wäre doch
viel schlauer zu sagen wir erhöhen jetzt
für eine begrenzte zeit zumindest den
regelsatz ohne lange beantragen ohne
langes warten wann es denn ausgezahlt
wird gerade für kinder und gerade
übrigens auch für alte wäre das so
dringend notwendig meine bank wir werden
uns um die wirtschaft um menschen und um
unsere grundlegenden rechte und
freiheiten natürlich schlug ich als auch
deutsche wenn ich mir vorstelle dass der
aufenthalt draußen eingeschränkt wird
und menschen wieder auf der straße nach
ihrem ausweis und nach dem woher und
wohin von der polizei gefragt werden
aber ich weiß dass heute unsere
verfassung die basis unseres handelns
ist und der rechtsstaat der rahmen die
demokratische kontrolle ist eben nicht
ausgesetzt und deswegen freut es mich
besonders dass es uns noch gelungen ist
die bundesregierung zu überzeugen dass
der bundestag das parlament selbst den
epidemie heute ausruft und nicht die
regierung
das ist
das ist es ist doch wenn es kein
misstrauen das ist kein misstrauen
sondern es geht darum dass wir zeigen
können gerade auch in der not
funktioniert unsere demokratie und
dieses gesetz müssten wir gemeinsam weil
wir in ruhigen zeiten uns noch einmal
darüber beugen wollen gut so danke den
kolleginnen und kollegen von der fdp von
der linken und auch der regierung für
die kooperation an dieser stelle meine
damen meine herren ist es zu früh lehren
aus der krise zu ziehen
aber schon jetzt ist klar dieses virus
die pandemie können wir nur gemeinsam
bekämpfen
die auswirkung der corvette 19 krise bei
unseren nachbarn in italien und spanien
sind schockierend und die nachrichten
brechen mir ich glaube uns allen das
herz und es beschämt mich als europäerin
dass unsere erste reaktion war die
grenzen zu schließen es beschämt mich
dass andere hilfe schneller bei den
europäischen nachbarn ankamen als unsere
gut dass wir das jetzt korrigieren gut
dass jetzt in krankenhäusern in
deutschland in baden württemberg in
sachsen in nordrhein-westfalen andere
länder werden wohl folgen patientinnen
und patienten aus diesen ländern
behandelt werden
wir müssen den mut
jeden tag in dieser saison auch das
gebot der solidarität für unsere
nachbarn im blick haben und es gibt
instrumente dafür der esm oder auch die
kfw wären möglichkeiten das
hinzubekommen diese krise werden wir nur
europäisch gemeinsam bewältigen können
und und es ist an uns zu zeigen dass wir
auch an andere denken die so unendlich
viel weniger haben die der krise kaum
noch begegnen können in afrika im jemen
in moria es kann uns nicht egal sein
auch denen zu helfen die es selbst gar
nicht können meine damen und herren
diese krise hat pink cross hat das
gezeigt ist eine wie immer sie bringt
entweder das schlechteste oder das beste
hervor
und ich bin dann zwei das
toilettenpapier käufe und hamster rey
nicht mehr das bild dieser krise
ausmachen und vielleicht das ist auch zu
früh zuversichtlich zu sein
aber das was wir heute erleben
das sind die guten beispiele vom anfang
die wir erweitern könnten wahrscheinlich
jede und jeder von uns bei ihm zu hause
oder aus dem netz meine damen und herren
wir könnten jetzt anfangen uns zu
separieren die einen bleiben zu hause
und die anderen machen party im park
mal davon abgesehen dass bewohner nicht
nur alte und schwache trifft das ist
nicht meine vorstellung von einer
gesellschaft das ist übrigens auch nicht
meine vorstellung davon wie wir diese
krise bewältigen können und wie wir die
wirtschaft wieder auf gute beine stellen
können danach nach dieser krise brauchen
wir eine gemeinsame anstrengung von
allen mit kraft mit fantasie gemeinsam
mit genügend geld übrigens für
investitionen für das was notwendig ist
die investitionen die nachhaltig sind
ökologisch sinnvoll und übrigens auch
europäisch meine damen und herren
all das stellt uns vor riesige
herausforderungen und an uns hier und an
die menschen da draußen bin ich sage
bleiben sie zu hause und bleiben sie
behütet halten wir abstand und halten
wir zusammen
vielen dank auf katrin göring-eckardt
betonte dass derzeit kooperation vor
konkurrent schule demokratisches
miteinander statt gegeneinander sei das
motto dieser tag
die grünen fordern jedoch auch eine
bessere bezahlung für pfleger und
pflegerinnen nächster redner reif
mützenich fraktionsvorsitzender der spd
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das mag paradox
klingen
in einer zeit in der abstand der beste
schutz ist müssen wir zusammenstehen
nur gemeinsam können wir die
herausforderungen meistern im land aber
auch hier im deutschen bundestag und ja
die pandemie ist eine existenzielle
herausforderung für jeden die
gesellschaft und die ganze welt und die
erkrankung trifft höchstwahrscheinlich
einzelne gruppen besonders aber sie wird
sie trifft jeden unterschiedslos und
umfassend und das ist die existenzielle
herausforderung die die gesellschaften
die welt aber auch jeder einzelne nicht
nur wird begreifen müssen sondern die
wir auch meistern müssen deswegen will
ich sagen ja wir müssen zuerst allen
denen danken die uns helfen in dieser
schweren krise natürlich die
berufstätigen in der gesundheits in den
pflegeberufen im lebensmittelhandel im
transportgewerbe und ja sie werden heute
als systemrelevant benannt aber ihr lohn
ist nicht so wie wir ihn uns wünschen
deswegen ist es richtig dass die
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer zu
mindestens einigen wenigen bereichen den
tariflohn durchaus durch einmalzahlungen
erhöht aber jetzt kommt es eben darauf
an wir brauchen bessere tarife in
zukunft und dafür muss auch dieser
deutsche größter streit geraten
und ich will zugleich sagen
ich danke nachbarn vereinsmitglied und
fremden mitarbeitern in den verwaltungen
rentnerinnen und rentner pensionäre die
aus den erfahrungen ihres arbeitsplatzes
jetzt wieder zurückkehren und helfen
wollen aber ich danke auch den und auch
an die muss man erinnern die eben heute
nicht ihre verwandten treffen können
weil sie zu weit weg sind eben ihre
verwandten ihre angehörigen und ihre
freunde und leider gehört es auch zum
alltag heute dazu dass menschen von
ihrem verstorbenen angehörigen alleine
abschied nehmen müssen und dies nicht in
der solidarität der trauergemeinschaft
tun können
auch an diese personen müssen wir
erinnern und das ist auch meine
anteilnahme die ich heute hier vom
deutschen bundestag aussagen möchte
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen unser
vorrangiges ziel ist leben retten und
gleichzeitig die wirtschaftlichen und
sozialen herausforderungen halbwegs in
grenzen halten nicht mehr aber auch
nicht weniger
deswegen müssen wir die medizinische
versorgung sichern und die staatlichen
hilfen die die bundesregierung zusammen
mit den fraktionen dieses deutschen
bundestages entwickelt hat auch für die
nächsten monate zu sichern
möglicherweise reicht dies nicht aus wir
müssen nach steuern wir müssen auch
schauen was wir besser machen können in
der tat wir werden fehler machen aber es
ist wichtig dass jetzt liquidität
zuschüsse rechtssicherheit geschaffen
wird damit ein schutzschirm über den
einzelnen aber eben auch über die
gesellschaft ausgebreitet werden kann
aber das kann nicht alleine dieser
deutsche bundestag machen deswegen ist
es für mich motivierend dass es ein
pilotabschluss in der metallindustrie
gegeben hat oder in der
systemgastronomie
wo eben den beschäftigten zusätzliche
leistungen zuerkannt werden damit sie
diese krise aber auch ihre zukunft an
diesem arbeitsplatz besser gestalten
können weil eben die kurzarbeit das
kurzarbeitergeld auf gestoppt wird und
deswegen sage ich und fordere auch die
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber auf
gehen sie auf die gewerkschaften zu und
verhandeln sie weitere verträge damit
die arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
abgesichert sind und weil der staat
meine damen und herren 100 prozent der
sozialversicherungsbeiträge unternimmt
können die unternehmen ist an ihre aber
an ihrer arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer weiterreichen das ist der
beste weg um soziale sich
auch zu schaffen und gleichzeitig meine
damen und herren später werden sich
geschichten an diesen entscheidenden
wochen weltweit messen und dann wird
eine wahrscheinlich der ideen seien die
rückbesinnung auf den staat ja auf den
starken staat aber ich sage als
sozialdemokrat insbesondere auf einen
sozialen auf einen demokratischen staat
und das war immer das leitmotiv auch
gewesen auf dieser seite wir haben das
in den haushaltsdebatten in den
vergangenen jahren gemacht aber ich will
auch gleichzeitig sagen wir werden nicht
alle sorgen nehmen können die menschen
haben sorgen um ihr leben um das ihre
angehörigen aber ich kann versprechen
dass wir versuchen wollen die folgen so
gut wie möglich einzuhegen und zu
versuchen auch zu mildern und deswegen
bin ich auch den oppositionsfraktionen
dankbar dass wir das in den vergangenen
tagen auch gemeinsam schaffen konnten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sowie das
virus die ganze welt trifft so
unterschiedlich sind leider auch die
reaktionen
grob gesagt es gibt zwei gruppen es gibt
die die handeln und nicht danach fragen
woher was kommt aber es gibt eben auch
die die zwar auch handeln
die manches kleinreden aber vor allem
auf andere zeigen ich bin froh in einem
land in einem politischen system zu
leben wo eben nicht andere
verantwortlich gemacht werden wo wir
nicht nach schuldigen suchen sondern wo
wir eben versuchen diese herausforderung
auch gerecht zu werden das macht
deutschland das nachkriegsdeutschland
innerhalb der europäischen union aus und
deswegen
müssen wir auch offene worte an die
richten die zb wie der ungarische
ministerpräsident orban von der
italienischen krankheit sprechen lässt
oder herrn schramm der vom bbu hamburg
spricht das ist peinlich und das geht
nicht unter demokraten und schon gar
nicht innerhalb der europäischen union
und genau deswegen bin ich auch vielen
dankbar
nicht nur die solidarität üben sondern
dass wir menschen jetzt erkrankte
menschen aus italien in leipzig
aufgenommen haben in den krankenhäusern
dass wir grenznahe krankenhäuser
geöffnet haben und dass wir italien aber
auch spanien letztlich diese solidarität
geben aber das zeigt daneben auch für
die zukunft wir müssen diese
institutionen die sich um die
zusammenarbeit bemühen dann auch
unterstützen und ihnen nicht die
mitgliedsbeiträge vorenthalten wie es
einige tun wenn es um die vereinten
nationen geht die
weltgesundheitsorganisation ist die
institutionen die uns am besten mit
helfen kann durch die krise zu leiten
deswegen will ich wohl dass wir teil
dieser welt gemeinschaft sind und ja
wenn die existenziellen
herausforderungen so sind wie wir sie
alle beschrieben haben so ist natürlich
die verbreitung des virus auch ein
tribut an die verdichtung von räumen und
prozessen
25 jahre hat es im mittelalter gedauert
bis die pest nach europa gekommen ist
heute innerhalb von 25 tagen arbeit
handel bewegung reisen das hat natürlich
mit dazu bewirkt und wir werden das
nicht zurückschrauben konnte im
gegenteil ich glaube dass wir nicht an
der globalisierung zweifeln dürfen
sondern wir müssen alles dafür tun dass
diese globalisierung gestaltet wird dass
die internationale arbeitsteilung
natürlich auch die lieferketten
überdacht werden müssen und insbesondere
in ganz wichtigen bereichen müssen sich
die unternehmen fragen ob das was sie in
den vergangenen jahren gemacht haben
heute noch das richtige ist und ich sage
auch der staat muss dann auch mit dem
ordnungsrecht nacharbeiten wenn wir
bestimmte bereiche eben nicht so sichern
können wie es für das überleben der
menschen notwendig denke an arzneimittel
an die produktion von schutzmasken und
vieles andere auch meine damen und
herren nicht jeden preis der
globalisierung dürfen wir zahlen und
deswegen möchte ich zum abschluss sagen
ja es wird eine zeit nach der pandemie
geben aber dann kommt es auf die
schlussfolgerungen an
und wir haben ja in den vergangenen
tagen schon schwachpunkte entdeckten
müssen insbesondere wenn es um die
digitalisierung geht um die
zuverlässigkeit
ob dort eben im bildungsbereich und in
vielen anderen bereichen auch dies
ausreicht wo wir investiert haben und
nein wir müssen mehr investieren gerade
eben in die menschen in diese
infrastruktur und ich glaube das kann
der staat meine damen und herren auch
tun und das sind die herausforderungen
die ich auch in zukunft sehe aber ich
will auch sagen es müssen sich auch
diejenigen die frage stellen ob das wie
sie die moderne arbeitswelt mit
begleiten wollen
der richtige weg ist natürlich müssen
wir jetzt den solo selbstständigen
helfen aber ich will zum beispiel auch
daran erinnern
vielleicht gibt es lehren aus der
vergangenheit lehren aus der zb der
arbeiter bewegung die sich damals
zusammen geschlossen hat in einem
genossenschaftswesen in solidarität dass
man sich gegenseitig hilft und deswegen
will ich sagen wir müssen die jetzigen
folgen bewältigen aber nicht nachlassen
was in zukunft notwendig ist und
deswegen werden wir mit voller
konzentration und überzeugung auch in
den kommenden wochen unsere
verantwortung wahrnehmen
das tun wir vor dem hintergrund unserer
geschichte
und für unser land bleiben sie gesund
weil sie nicht von der spd betonte es
gehe nun darum leben zu retten und
gleichzeitig den schaden für die
wirtschaft möglichst klein zu halten
möglicherweise müsse es aber weitere
hilfsmaßnahmen geben
nächster redner ist peter böhringer von
der nahen osten
[Applaus]
herr präsident verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen die gesundheit der menschen hat
immer priorität
die afg hat medizinisch derzeit keine
gesicherten besseren erkenntnisse als
die berater der bundesregierung
wir unterstützen daher maßnahmen der
unmittelbaren existenz und
gesundheitsfürsorge etwa die
milliardensummen für die krankenhäuser
und kleinunternehmer sowie maßnahmen
gegen die weitere ausbreitung der
pandemie corona patienten in
krankenhäusern oder heute noch gesunde
die aber morgen corona patienten sein
könnten müssen sich also keine sorgen
machen dass ihre behandlung am geld
scheitert etwa für schutzausrüstung oder
beatmungsgeräte zugleich sind aber viele
der heute von der bundesregierung
vorgeschlagenen shutdown maßnahmen nicht
nur einschneidend sondern in der
nachkriegszeit präzedenzlosen minister
scholz hat es ja mehr oder weniger auch
bestätigt und schon nach wenigen wochen
sind diese maßnahmen ihrerseits für
viele menschen existenzgefährdend es
geht hier explizit nicht um das völlig
unbestritten erforderliche unterbinden
von gefährlichen corona partys und auch
die temporäre minimierung der
sozialkontakte
so hat das auch ist wird von der afg der
zeit mitgetragen
doch wir müssen weiterdenken ein ganzes
land in stillstand zu versetzen führt
schon nach kurzer zeit für viele
menschen unternehmen zu zum teil
irreversiblen folgewirkungen psychische
belastungen durch
freiheitsbeschränkungen
betriebsschließungen finanzielle
notlagen durch entlassungen seien
eingriffe in bürgerrechte und eigentum
ganz zu schweigen
es ist eine illusion dass staatliche
gelder also steuergelder der
gesellschaft selbst auch nur annähernd
ausreichend könnten die derzeit fast
völlig unterbunden wertschöpfung des
privatsektors zu ersetzen
die deutschen unternehmen eher
wirtschaft werte in höhe von dreieinhalb
billionen euro pro jahr also jeden monat
300 milliarden
der staat könnte selbst nur die hälfte
davon mit dem heute vorliegenden
gewaltigen maßnahmenpaket noch nicht
einmal für sechs monate ersetzen
darum ja heute musste ich noch alles den
medizinischen notwendigkeiten
unterordnen doch die maßnahmen müssen
angesichts der horrenden finanziellen
psychischen gesellschaftlichen folgen
des aktuellen stillstands in sehr kurzen
abständen immer neu hinterfragt werden
durch uns den gesetzgeber auf basis
eines sich ständig ändernden
erkenntnisstand es etwa zu mensch zur
entwicklung von impfstoffen oder zu
hoffentlich bei zurückgehenden
fallzahlen einige entwicklung im ausland
lassen ja hier etwas hoffnung daher
unser general antrag zur heutigen
debatte auf enge zeitliche befristung
wieder maßnahmen dem ich sie im
interesse deutschlands inständig bitte
zuzustimmen
in drei bis vier wochen wird die erste
spritze ich betone die erste spitze der
korona pandemie vorüber sein
die seit einigen tagen nach langem
zögern der regierung nun verfügten
massnahmen des stotterns und der
grenzschließung werden natürlich greifen
die intensivstation werden dann das
schlimmste hinter sich haben übrigens
machen unsere ärztinnen und ärzte
pfleger und krankenhaus schwestern einen
exzellenten job so dass es bislang in
deutschland erheblich weniger tote gibt
als prognostiziert dafür von hier aus
herzlichen dank niko oder käse mit dem
april zwar leider noch nicht überwunden
sein
aber trotzdem wird bei laufenden
volkswirtschaftlichen schäden von über
50 milliarden euro pro woche ein
wiederhochfahren des landes unumgänglich
sein ein langsames unser antrag schafft
die voraussetzung dafür dass der
bundestag dem land diese meines
erachtens lebensnotwendige option erhält
ebenso lebensnotwendig wie die direkten
maßnahmen gegen korona die alternative
für deutschland nimmt somit heute oder
verantwortung in zeiten der pandemie war
doch wir fordern mut fordern unbedingt
eine zeitliche begrenzung und
überprüfung der heutigen corona
bedingten eilmaßnahmen je nach änderung
der lage
der bundestag soll sich bis zur
überwindung dieser gesundheitskrise
regelmäßig damit beschäftigen ob und
welche maßnahmen noch absolut zwingend
sind und wie der gesamtplan und der
ausstiegsplan der bundesregierung
aussieht denen das vorliegende
gesetzespaket nicht ansatzweise
darstellt der afc west die menschen
nicht im stich wieder die alten und
kranken in der intensivbetten noch die
kurzarbeiter noch die arbeitslosen in
den derzeit geschlossenen betrieben das
feld tragen wir alles mitteilte haben
wir es schon mitgetragen aber die
regierungs hybris der totalen steuerung
und finanzierung der ganzen gesellschaft
durch einen allgewaltigen start ist
schon in normalen zeiten verfehlt bei
der korona krise erst recht dauerhaft
kann nur eine wieder anlaufen die
privatwirtschaft die summen
erwirtschaften die man für eine optimale
gesundheitsversorgung der menschen
benötigt von nichts kommt nichts strom
kommt aus der steckdose und staatliche
hilfsgelder gelder kommen real nicht aus
einem kfw-kredit schöpfungsprozess
sondern
sondern muss von den steuern eben jener
menschen die ja eigentlich selbst mit
diesem geld gesund erhalten werden
sollen
man kann sich nicht dauerhaft aus einer
krise drucken das land muss wieder
selbst als wirtschaften kommen da unsere
rechnung nach spätestens drei monaten
wenigstens langsam
das deckt sich übrigens auch mit den
schätzungen des sachverständigenrats der
bundesregierung selbst von dem irgendwie
heute in dieser debatte noch keine rede
war
auf dauer ist nur eine halbwegs
vermögende und freie gesellschaft auch
eine gesunde gesellschaft überschuldete
verarmte länder waren überall in der
welt und der geschichte auch
gesundheitlich angeschlagene länder mit
geringer lebensdauer der menschen die
kollateralschäden des jetzigen zustands
werden schon in wenigen wochen untragbar
für die wirtschaft und unerträglich für
die menschen werden
stimmen sie darum bitte unseren anträgen
auf enge befristung und regelmäßige
überprüfung der vorgeschlagenen
maßnahmen zu vielen dank dieter
böhringer von der afg ist vorsitzender
des haushaltsausschusses erfordert eine
ständige überprüfung der maßnahmen diese
sollte nur zeitlich begrenzt gelten ein
baldiges hochfahren der wirtschaft hält
er für unumgänglich spätestens nach drei
monaten nächster redner alexander
dobrindt vorsitzender der csu
landesgruppe der präsident sehr geehrte
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die krone krise wird tiefe
spuren bei wirtschaft und gesellschaft
in unserem land und in europa
hinterlassen
ja und dabei ist es unsere aufgabe alles
zu tun dass wir die folgen mildern im
medizinischen im sozialen im
wirtschaftlichen und dabei wird sich ja
nicht alles verhindern lassen und es
wird sich auch nicht jedes problem lösen
lassen aber wir werden alle
möglichkeiten die uns zur verfügung
stehen einsetzen wir haben die kraft in
diesem land solidarisch zusammen steht
zu stehen und deswegen meine damen und
herren ist dieses gesetzespaket was wir
heute verabschieden
der größte solidarpakt unserer
gemeinschaft seit der deutschen
wiedervereinigung und der blick liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und meine damen
und herren heute hier ja auch in den
plenarsaal in kombination mit dem
gesetzespaket das wir verabschieden es
gibt den eindruck unserer situation
ziemlich genau wider
wir gehen in diesen tagen auf abstand
man kann es hier sehen aber politik
gesellschaft und wirtschaft stehen eng
zusammen das ist der auftrag auch aus
diesem gesetzespaket und deswegen meine
damen und herren wir nehmen diese krise
die wir uns nicht ausgesucht haben in
all ihrer härte an und werden sie mit
aller kraft bekämpfen
und in krisensituationen wir haben ja in
der vergangenheit schon auch einige
hinter uns gebracht er wird immer gerne
über die systemrelevanz gesprochen
und gerade erleben wir jeden tag was
systemrelevanz in unserem ganzen land
vor ort bedeutet es sind die menschen in
ihren berufen sind die krankenschwestern
die ärzte die supermarkt kräfte die
polizistinnen und viele mehr
meine damen und herren wenn unser ganzes
land runterfährt müssen diese menschen
richtig raus fahren und es kommt
deswegen jetzt mehr denn je auf diese
menschen an das ist hier schon mehrmals
heute erwähnt worden
ich hoffe nur dass diese erkenntnis auch
über die krise hinweg andauern meine
damen und herren dankeschön an alle die
hier ihre arbeit
klar ist aber auch genauso wie diese
menschen ihren hohen einsatz bringen
muss die politik ihrer verantwortung
nachkommen deswegen kommt der bundestag
auch hier zusammen wir zeigen wir sind
handlungsfähig auch in schwierigen
zeiten gemeinsam mit der bundesregierung
bereit massnahmen zu treffen und
deswegen möchte ich an dieser stelle
auch meinen dank zum ausdruck bringen
wir haben in den letzten tagen intensive
beratungen zwischen parlament zwischen
den fraktionen und der bundesregierung
gehabt ausdrücklich dankt hier an die
frau bundeskanzlerin ausdrücklich dank
auch an den bundesfinanzminister an den
gesundheitsminister an den
bundesinnenminister und dem
wirtschaftsminister wir haben in
schwierigsten zeiten unter schweren
bedingungen gezeigt dass wir gemeinsam
in der lage sind entscheidungen zu
treffen auch über die eine oder andere
ideologische schwelle zu treten im sinne
der gemeinschaftlich guten
entscheidungen herzlichen dank auch an
die opposition an dieser stelle die
krone pandemie ist nicht nur eine enorme
gesundheitliche herausforderung sie ist
auch ein stresstest für unsere
wirtschaft und unsere gesellschaft und
wir kennen das eben ja aus den krisen
der vergangenheit der immobilienkrise in
den usa der bankenkrise auf der ganzen
welt der staatsschuldenkrise im euroraum
das man enger zusammenrücken muss und
wir haben aus diesen krisen in der
vergangenheit auch natürlich gelernt und
wir haben durch diese krisen unser land
sicher geführt der unterschied
allerdings zu den krisen der
vergangenheit und dieser ist das
immobilien oder banken oder euro krise
ja da war auch die möglichkeit und das
risiko dass andere sektoren mit
betroffen werden aber es war
sektorspezifische die krisensituation
das corona virus heute betrifft jetzt
bereits unsere gesellschaft und
wirtschaft als ganzes und deswegen ist
es ein außergewöhnlicher zustand und wir
müssen bereit sein in einer
außergewöhnlichen krise auch
außergewöhnliche maßnahmen zu
entscheiden und es ist eine
außergewöhnliche maßnahme bei der damen
und herren wenn man ein paket schnürt
ein historisches paket schnürt von 1400
milliarden euro das ist so circa die
gesamtsumme aller maßnahmen an krediten
an garantien an schutzmaßnahmen die wir
heute gemeinsam hier entscheiden drei
starke schutzschirme um die es geht ein
schutzschirm für das gesundheitssystem
ein schutzschirm für die wirtschaft und
ein schutzschirm für die bürger privat
und in der arbeit meine damen und herren
es gibt sehr viele länder die sich genau
solche schutzschirme aktuell nicht
leisten können werden wir können uns das
leisten weil wir in der vergangenheit
solide gewirtschaftet solide
gehaushaltet haben weil wir darauf
geachtet haben dass wir in der
vergangenheit keine neuen schulden
anhäufen
deswegen können wir jetzt mit diesen
großen maßnahmenpaket gegen die krise
ankämpfen meine damen und herren wir
investieren in unsere krankenhäuser
jetzt mit einem großen paket ist eine
der aktuell wichtigsten maßnahmen wenn
man in unsere nachbarländer würmer nach
italien schaut dann tut es einem herzen
weh wenn man sieht dass nicht genügend
betten nicht genügend intensivstationen
zur verfügung stehen
wir stützen die wirtschaft weil
wirtschaften bedeutet immer
zusammenzukommen wirtschaft bringt
menschen zusammen
sowohl in der freizeit als auch in der
produktion als auch in den
dienstleistungen vieles davon ist
aktuell nicht mehr möglich deswegen
brauchen wir diesen schutzschirm für
unsere wirtschaft wir brauchen ihn mit
direkthilfen mit liquiditätskredite und
übrigens auch mit der möglichkeit auf
beteiligung auf staatlicher beteiligung
in unternehmen meine damen und herren
und deswegen auch an dieser stelle den
hinweis alles was wir in den vergangenen
wochen und monaten gelernt haben
überproduktion über mangel über
nichtverfügbarkeit von wichtigsten
elementen von medikamenten von
medizinischen produkten wir werden uns
auch darüber unterhalten müssen wie wir
produktion von kritischen gütern wieder
nach deutschland und europa zurück holen
es ist falsch
nur eine region auf der welt für
wichtigste produktionsgüter für uns
zuständiges meine damen und herren
und ja wir werden eine ausnahme bei der
schuldenbremse machen
wir haben das intensiv beraten
finanzminister sie haben dabei unsere
unterstützung wir wissen dass das keine
ganz einfache aufgabe ist und deswegen
ist damit verbunden auch die zwingende
vereinbarungen wie diese 100 milliarden
euro zurückbezahlt werden aber es jetzt
ein notwendiger schritt den wir auch
gemeinsam gehen weil wir maximalen
einsatz zum schutz unserer bürger
erreichen müssen meine damen und herren
dieser große solidaritätspakt ist kein
schlussstrich heute er ist ein signal
ein signal für solidarität weil
solidarität keine einzelfall
entscheidung sondern eine haltung ist
und deswegen werden wir auch wenn
notwendig über weitere maßnahmen
gemeinsam hier beratend und entscheidend
es liegt eine große wegstrecke vor uns
bleiben sie gesund und gottes segen für
sie alle
alexander dobrindt von der csu sprach
vom größten solidarpakt seit der
wiedervereinigung politik wirtschaft und
gesellschaft stünden zusammen wie nie
zuvor
außergewöhnliche maßnahmen seien jetzt
berechtigt es folgt jetzt
gesundheitsminister jens spahn
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die kogit 19 epidemie verändert
unser aller alltag unserer privat- und
unser arbeitsleben
wir erleben tiefe einschnitte in die
bürgerlichen freiheiten
daran gibt es nichts zu beschönigen
darum gibt es andererseits auch nichts
zu dramatisieren
die bürgerinnen und bürger schätzen die
freiheit in unserem land sind aber auch
bereit
aus guten gründen eine zeit lang
auf freiheiten zu verzichten und
deswegen ist es auch so wichtig dass wir
immer wieder gut und transparent
erklären und herleiten was wir warum tun
die bereitschaft mitzuhelfen ist gerade
enorm
die übergroße mehrheit der deutschen
bleibt so oft wie möglich zu hause
diese disziplin und dieses
verantwortungsgefühl retten jetzt leben
auch die solidarität mit allen die
täglich für uns im einsatz sind ist groß
wir alle wissen wie viel die frauen und
männer in den krankenhäusern den praxen
in den supermärkten den
versorgungsbetrieben in den behörden und
an vielen anderen stellen gerade live
dafür können wir dank selbst habe wie
viele andere miterlebt dass sich und wie
sich patientinnen und patienten und
kunden bei denen bedanken die jetzt für
sie da sind
das freut mich denn es zeigt wir kämpfen
als gesellschaft gerade sehr
entschlossen und gegen geschlossen gegen
krohne die alle spüren wieder stärker
dass wir einander brauchen weil das eine
herausforderung ist die wir nur zusammen
meistern können wenn wir wenn wir in
dieser krise ein neues wir-gefühl
entwickeln wird uns das auch für die
zukunft stärken denn es wird eine zeit
nach krone geben
vor allem täglichen krisenmanagement ist
es wichtig auch dass im blick zu haben
jetzt geht es darum gemeinsam diese
krise zu bewältigen
dafür war es wichtig dass bund und
länder entschieden gehandelt haben die
entschlossener wer jetzt vorgehen desto
schneller können wir zurück in den
alltag finden die zeit die wir jetzt
gewinnen schützt unser gesundheitssystem
vor überlastung und überforderung
wir nutzen diese zeit um konzepte nicht
nur zu entwickeln sondern auch für die
umsetzung vorzubereiten wie wir
schrittweise auch beschränkungen wieder
aufheben können weil wir eben mit
verschiedenen anderen maßen
tatsächlich dann auch die verlangsamung
des virus auch in der zukunft
sicherstellen können und besondere
gruppen schützen können wir nutzen die
zeit um intensiv kapazitäten im land zu
verdoppeln gemeinsam mit den ländern und
den krankenhäusern wie schön wir nutzen
die zeit indem kliniken planbare
eingriffe verschieben und dadurch eben
frei wollen wir gewinnen um sich
vorzubereiten auf das was kommen kann
und all diese maßnahmen kosten geld und
für all diese maßnahmen brauchen die
kliniken eine finanzielle sicherheit
deshalb haben wir im kabinett
beschlossen die kliniken zu entlasten
durch pauschalen für freie betten durch
zusätzliches geld für die pflege durch
vor allem liquidität die sie jetzt
schnell brauchen und unterstützung auch
finanziell für durch einen zuschuss für
intensivbetten und wir werden das
infektionsschutzgesetz erweitern
[Applaus]
bundesminister die handelswoche
als zweite maßnahme haben im kabinett
beschlossen das infektionsschutzgesetz
zu erweitern und zu präzisieren
wir erleben dass der föderalismus auch
in dieser krise seine stärke zeigt die
entscheidung dauern vielleicht manchmal
etwas länger werden dann aber in der
fläche durch 16 regierungen und die
vielen kommunen effektiv umgesetzt
deshalb sollen die kompetenzen der
länder nicht beschnitten werden
vielmehr wollen wir den grund in einer
epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite zusätzliche
handlungsmöglichkeiten geben und zwar
dort wo es sinnvoll ist und zunächst auf
ein jahr begrenzt
denn wir erleben ist ja dass es in einer
lage wie dieser die das ganze land
betrifft auch schnelle und landesweit
einheitliche entscheidungen braucht das
ersetzt die immense arbeit nicht die
länder und kommunen gerade leisten
es ergänzt sie wir alle wissen dass wir
diese krise nur deshalb bewältigen
können weil überall in unserem land
unzählige krisenmanager wenn manager vor
ort im einsatz sind
an ihnen allen in den städten und
gemeinden möchte ich hier ausdrücklich
danke sagen achten wir einander und
geben wir auf einen gesundheitsminister
sparen sei die wochen im krisenmodus
verteidigte den föderalismus aber auf
ein jahr begrenzt im notfall brauchen
der bund zusätzliche kompetenzen
nächster redner ist andreas jung von der
cdu
ihn und kollegen herr präsident er ist
als zutiefst bewegend empfunden dass wir
zu beginn der debatte bei ihren worten
gemeinsam im bundestag aufgestanden sind
wir haben uns damit symbolisch vor all
jenen verneigt die in dieser ernsten
situation in unserem land das land am
laufen halten die sich um ihre
mitmenschen kümmern und wir sagen
gemeinsam danke dass ihr da seid
[Applaus]
wir haben gemeinsam unser mitgefühl zum
ausdruck gebracht mit den angehörigen
der verstorbenen und wir sind gemeinsam
sorgsam aufmerksam
bezüglich dessen was in unserem land
passiert und es wird deutlich ist es
keine normale debatte so wie es eben
eine ganz außergewöhnliche situation ist
in unserem land und ich will es so sagen
es trifft uns ins herz wenn wir erleben
die kinder weinen weil sie nicht mit
ihren freunden spielen können wenn
großeltern ihre enkel nicht sehen können
wenn wir mitten in europa wieder grenzen
haben zu unseren partnern in regionen
die miteinander und gemeinsam leben wenn
mitarbeiter und unternehmen verzweifelt
sind aber keine arbeit da ist und alles
stillsteht wenn wir erleben wie vieles
dessen was unser leben im kern ausmacht
derzeit einfach abgesagt ist
gesellschaft geselligkeit kultur sport
begegnung und austausch es trifft uns
ins mark
wir hätten uns das nicht vorstellen
aber diese maßnahme sind richtig sie
sind notwendig weil es um menschenleben
geht weil es um gesundheit geht das ist
jetzt das gebot der stunde
deshalb müssen andere dinge zurückstehen
und war es auch die auswirkungen sind
dramatisch im sozialen im
wirtschaftlichen bereich in unserem
ganzen land die menschen sind in allen
kreisen in jeder gemeinde betroffen sind
kleine mittlere großen betriebe konzern
gleichermaßen betroffen deshalb müssen
wir gesagt und deshalb handeln werden
und weil es um menschenleben weil es um
gesundheit und weil es um existenzen
geht deshalb verschulden wir uns jetzt
deshalb aktivieren wir jetzt erstmals
den notfallplan der schuldenbremse und
genau für diese situation ist er da das
ist diese dramatische notsituation die
man seinerzeit im auge hatte deshalb
verschulden wir uns jetzt endlich
richtig und ich bin dankbar dass wir es
zu einem breiten konsens in den guten
geist in diesem haus tun können
mit zwei dinge dazu sagen erstens weil
wir in den letzten jahren gut
gewirtschaftet haben wir alle gemeinsam
die menschen die betriebe die
unternehmen aber auch wie er die wir
vernünftig mit dem geld umgegangen sind
weil wir gemeinsam gut gewirtschaftet
haben haben wir jetzt die kraft für die
krise um in dieser krise entschieden zu
handeln
und zweitens wir kommen wieder eine
ausnahme der schuldenbremse geht nur mit
tilgungsplan und dieser tilgungsplan ist
ein nachhaltigkeits versprechen
es ist das versprechen an unsere kinder
und enkel wir werden diese schulden
zurückbezahlen wenn es wieder losgeht
wenn die krise vorbei ist wenn in den
schulen auf unseren plätzen in den
betrieben in den unternehmen wenn wieder
leben in der bude ist wenn es wieder
summt und brummt dann werden wir diesen
tag heute nicht vergessen unser
versprechen wir werden es zurückzahlen
weil beides zusammengehört das
entschlossene handeln heute aber auch
die verantwortung für morgen und beiden
werden wir gerecht und ich bin dankbar
dass wir es in diesem guten geister
gemeinsam tun können
auch andreas jung von der cdu
verteidigte die hohe neuverschuldung für
die union deren ziel immer die
schuldenbremse eine schwarze null war
besonders schwer
wir nähern uns dem ende der debatte
nächster redner ist wirtschaftsminister
peter altmaier und kollegen nach zehn
jahren nach zehn guten jahr mit wachstum
mit rekordbeschäftigung sind wir was
unsere volkswirtschaft angeht in
schwerem wasser
die pandemie ist eine herausforderung
nicht nur für unser gesundheitssystem
sie betrifft nicht nur die gesundheit
und die sorgen von 83 millionen menschen
in deutschland und milliarden menschen
weltweit nein sie hat auch dazu geführt
dass in diesem jahr unsere wirtschaft
nicht wachsen wird und schrumpfen dass
viele
einen preis dafür zahlen durch weniger
verdienst weniger einnahmen weniger
wohlstand und in dieser situation
bewähren sich unser gesellschaftlicher
zusammenhalt unsere staatlichen
strukturen aber es ist eben auch eine
bewährung für das was unser land groß
gemacht hat nämlich unser system der
sozialen marktwirtschaft
die soziale marktwirtschaft ist deshalb
so genial weil sie die freie entfaltung
des unternehmertums ganz oben anstellt
aber die schwachen und diejenigen die
hilfe brauchen niemals alleine und im
stich lässt und deshalb meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren bin ich sehr
dankbar dass wir für einen augenblick
ideologischer debatten ausgeblendet
haben dass wir über parteigrenzen hinweg
erkannt haben dass eben die verlängerung
und die verbesserung von kurzarbeit
keine maßnahme ist die der wirtschaft
oder den arbeitnehmern nutzt sondern
allen gemeinsam sie erhält arbeitsplätze
sie erhält betriebe sie ermöglicht es
die durststrecken zu überwinden wenn wir
steuern stunden dann helfen wir damit
nicht nur unternehmen dass sie überleben
können sondern wir halten diesen
unternehmen auf ihre mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter weiter zu beschäftigen
wenn wir kreditlinien einräumen und
garantien geben
dann tragen wir dafür zu bei dass die
pandemie am ende nicht strukturen
zerstört die über 70 jahre gewachsen
sind die die einzigartigkeit unseres
landes wirtschaftlich aber auch sozial
und kulturell regen und ausmachen
und deshalb war es mir wichtig dass wir
zu anfang und zuerst auch über die hilfe
für die kleinen und die schutzlosen
gesprochen haben für die die keinen
zugang haben zu großen kreditlinien für
die die nicht die großen rücklagen haben
auch für die die für unser leben und
will den erfolg unserer marktwirtschaft
so wichtig sind drei millionen solo
selbstständige handwerker
beruflich schaffen arbeit für zehn
millionen menschen in deutschland und
deshalb war es richtig dass der
bundesfinanzminister und der
bundeswirtschaftsminister der
bundesregierung vorgeschlagen haben ein
schutzschirm von 50 milliarden euro zu
etablieren
es ist jetzt wichtig dass wir dies auch
umsetzen
schnell und unbürokratisch zur stunde
diskutieren wir über die frage wie das
gehen kann mit den bundesländern
gemeinsam in der nächsten woche werden
die zahlungen fällig für die
allermeisten die gewerbemieten büro
räume gemietet haben
wir wollen dass die banken die
sparkassen wissen dass die vermieter
wissen dass durch unseren schutzschirm
den wir aufgespannt haben sichergestellt
ist dass diese mieten bezahlt werden und
ja es ist unser ehrgeiz dass vor dem
ersten april die ersten zahlungen bei
den betroffenen unternehmen ankommen und
die handlungsfähigkeit des staates sich
auch in dieser schwierigen situation
bewährt meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren wir haben sicherlich wir haben
sicherlich nur einen ersten schritt
gemacht wir werden auch fehler gemacht
haben wir werden vielleicht einiges
korrigieren müssen
aber wir dürfen nicht nachlassen in
unserer entschlossenheit und
entschiedenheit die soziale
marktwirtschaft für die zukunft zu
erhalten und die wirtschaft
sachverständigen mit denen ich gestern
eine spannende telefonkonferenz
durchgeführt habe mit allen wesentlichen
ökonomen sie sagen und bestärken uns
darin dass sie auf dem richtigen weg
sind und wenn wir jetzt richtigen
besonnen handeln werden wir auch
wirtschaftlich stärker aus dieser krise
hervorgehen als wir in diese krise
hineingegangen sind unser ziel muss
darin bestehen dass die marktwirtschaft
diese bewährungsprobe mit bravour
besteht vielen dank
so wir blenden uns hier raus aus dieser
wirklich ungewöhnlichen denkwürdigen
sitzung des parlaments heute nachmittag
geht es im alten provider zweite und
dritte lesung einer fülle von anti
krisen gesetzen nochmals eine debatte am
freitag dann der bundesrat der bundestag
ist handlungsfähig auch in krisenzeiten
mit weniger abgeordneten als gewohnt die
kontrolle der regierung bleibe
gewährleistet so das signal heute aus
berlin
wir beenden jetzt unsere sendung über
den weiteren verlauf des sitzungstages
und über die abstimmungsergebnisse
informieren unsere folgenden aktuellen
heute -sendung ich sage tschüss bleiben
sie gesund bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]